hello friends i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today
i'm pretty excited to be doing the thing
that we are doing first up i do have to
say this video is sponsored by blinkist
uh that basically means that i get to do
an ad read about a product that i
actually really like and use rather than
letting
youtube pick its own ads and randomly
put them somewhere but just to intro
this
what i'm about to show you is a webtoon
um that
i voice the lead character in which is
my first time
voicing a lead character and it's a
performance that i'm actually pretty
happy with
i've been voice acting for a while and
some of the performances i think are
terrible
some of them i like this is a very
different process because this is my
first
um animated thing that i've voice acted
on there is more coming out this year
but in this case it's like animated
to my words really well and i'm also
doing an american accent the whole time
and i frankly think i am a much better
voice actor when i'm not using my own
voice
so it's in part that you know i what i
use this channel for
is to share things i'm excited about
that's always kind of been my mo here
time to inform
or share things i'm excited about
because there's so much negativity on
the internet
why not be positive but also that i just
wanted to give it the attention because
i think even
completely removing my involvement it's
just a really heartwarming
short so it's called the monster under
my bed it's published on uh
webtoon as an animated short film i'll
leave a link in the description if you
just want to check it out yourself
i was directed by issa from the rooster
teeth animation team and she was
fantastic she just made me so
comfortable
with what i was doing it's based on a
story written by um
marvin w who i'll also leave a link
below that was basically
adapted into a screenplay by jordan also
from the roosty animation team
into this animated short film there's
plenty more i could say
um obviously loved working with them
let's just press play shall we let's go
that's me
[Music]
leo i told you you cannot scare me
i'm too smart for your little game so
stop trying it's getting embarrassing
it's hard for me to believe that's my
voice
my heart in fact i read trying to
accomplish something again and again and
again and expecting a different outcome
is the definition of insanity boring
boring boring boring boring you're so
boring sasha honey that's exactly why
you have no friends
amazed that she didn't respond more
strongly to having her french cut off
you're too smart to be afraid of things
i bet you're not even scared of
the dark of course not
the way they did that's so nice leo
could you please
i'm sure you're definitely not scared of
the monster under your bed
can you even prove there's a monster
under my bed hmm
can you prove there isn't
i don't remember if my sister did stuff
like that to me when i was younger dare
you
i'm a genius in my own way you're
dripping
oh my favorite shirt i'm going to bed
but what are you gonna do about the
monster i have a plan
say there is a monster under my bed i'll
just sleep there
so that it can't oh wow the way they
edit audiences
so you just want to know i just set it
into a mic very cool
a small price to pay gotta say yeah
really outsmarted that monster
well have a good night sashimi that's
not my name
the direction for this bit was really
specific
i had to make all right the little
grunting noises
like i sound like you're spacing
what's going on i can't see
it's really pretty
[Music]
i knew it i knew there was a monster
under my bed
you look very weird by the way what no
you're the monster under my bed i
figured if i was under there then you
couldn't be
no way i had the same thought
nothing guess you're stuck here
hmm wait the light was out before
let's try making it dark again i want
one now
i want a monster under my bed
they're connected so cool wow good
thinking
you're really smart thank you thanks
my brother says being smart makes me
boring no way
i wish i could be that smart my brain's
always trailing off thinking of
different stuff
all the other kids make fun of me saying
my head's in the clouds
but then i like to imagine that makes me
king of the clouds
what's your name your highness i'm sasha
i'm oh bless you
no that's my name achoo no artu
not even close or you can give me a
nickname if you want
hmm he's so cute sneeze
i have a nickname i have a nickname
you're still up
who are you talking to mama this is
sasha she's the monster who lives under
my bed
well okay you and your invisible friend
keep it down
it's time for bed good night you saw
while she was directing me
like a perfect impression of her funny
odd
maybe it has to do with the bed like
whoever goes through the portal can't be
seen on the other side
oh i bet that's it sasha you're the
smartest
i can't wait to be friends and visit
each other's rooms
you you want to be
friends i'd be
honored to be friends with the king of
the clouds
come on my leash let's check out my room
it is now time for an ad read thanks to
blinkist and brought to you by my
shirt that is really not having a good
time with the green screen
so if you didn't already know blinkist
is an app that basically gives you
non-fiction books
in mobile format as a subscription
service what that means and why i think
it's really cool is that you basically
have
access to very concise easy to consume
things that can teach you a lot of
information it is ultimately a very good
way to learn
trending things right now are the three
secrets to effective time
investment but there are also things for
boosting productivity or
changing your career or setting better
goals for yourself and obviously you can
kind of choose whatever thing is
that you want to learn more about and i
think the thing that i like the most
about it being bite-sized is that there
are so many points of downtime during
your day like waiting for a game to
install where you could read something
for 10 minutes and learn a tremendous
amount because they make them so easily
digestible and really concise
so basically when they reached out i
just thought this was something that
very much aligns with um
you know me being extremely pro learning
and something that is really accessible
to a lot of people
the first 100 people who sign up to
blink is using my link which is
blinkist.compierce i'll have it in the
description below
will get their first week 100 unlimited
access
completely for free no catch and then
you will also get 25
off if after that you decide to join up
for a full membership so yeah
check it out that is blinkist.com alana
pierce
that one and we're back and now it's in
the future still me
how about that one oh no way he looks
like he's never opened a book in his
life
this sounds a lot more like oh he could
how about that one still not in a girl
sneeze
well i still can't tell the difference
oh there's three glosses i think that's
enough of this game
not like any of them want to talk to me
anyway you are the weirdo talking to the
air
well how about you you have any luck
talking to that one girl yet
no i just can't get the nerve these
glasses make me self-conscious
plus i woke up with the mother of all
pimples this morning
gee only had a face full of fur to cover
it
well i know it's there the like focus
on that shot is really cool
that one
no i don't even know him he's just some
weird guy from french history who's
always doodling
ugh weird just like you
i gotta get to class i'll meet up with
you at the dorms later
it's so cute i feel like you're like
keep saying that king of the fur then
king of the clouds these days
it's getting harder and harder to
squeeze under there
soon i'm not gonna fit and we won't be
able to see each other
yeah it's getting hard for me too
no
you still talking to your invisible
monster friend obviously that's a
brother just to make some real
point please i just wanted to see if you
were coming to my birthday party this
saturday and if you were planning to
bring a plus one but
then i remembered you're a loser with no
social life god that's
psycho calling just to push my buttons
ugh he even managed to cut my bangs
again
i uh i was just putting these flyers
kind of just opened who
were you talking to my invisible monster
friend
oh where is it yeah i wouldn't want to
accidentally
sit on him uh he's over here
so you could sit on the bed
what's he look like i could try drawing
him
well uh he's a big furry nerd
with four arms three eyes okay
what else he's got this huge
pimple on his face hey a small
cute tail like a dog
and and
what are you doing this saturday
didn't know the time jump
you don't regret never getting to see
him no no he was your monster
plus i'm pretty sure i wasn't it could
be the first time that he was making
another crown
speaking of monsters is it ready daddy
yep
come on it's coronation time
by the power vested in me through
being dad i hereby crown you
king of the clouds king
of the clouds
wow all right your highness
may i escort you to bed for your royal
map
i love the way the backgrounds are all
slightly textured
it's really nice
it's really nice okay
sweet dreams mama
what is it pumpkin can can you
leave the light on the dark is scary i
was
worried that i'd be covering up my
webcam i can do that slip back
out but there's nothing to worry about
you know why
so cute because there's a monster under
your bed
but they call visit each other
[Music]
i just think it's um really
unique cute little thing
super well made it was really fun to be
a part of like a genuine honor to be a
part of it
let me pause that and um i just thought
that i would share it with everyone yeah
i'll leave a link if you want to check
it out without my
commentary but yeah it was really a lot
of fun
something that um just sort of popped up
on my 2020 that
was just very enjoyable so yeah
obviously i would have made this video
um regardless of the sponsorship or not
but it felt like one that made sense to
to slaughter it so thank you to blake is
sponsoring the channel the link will be
in the description below and uh
i will see you guys next time my hands
are still
sort of in bad shape that hurts a lot
that bright pink
um hoping i can play the resident evil
demo at some point this week
and yeah get back to streaming with my
own hands rather than watching friends
uh hopefully if i haven't already i
might already try the medium i'm not
sure i might just have to like really
pad my hands so they don't hurt too much
but
anyway that's it for me today everyone i
hope you guys enjoyed it check it out
yourselves if you want to
it's very cool i will see you next time
bye